these are my friends Shawn and Jack Jack
you the new driver normally that's an
exciting time but when you're black you
know when I'm when I'm driving they you
know it's crazy to actual have a name
for driving while black
whenever I see coughs I always make sure
to put my hands on top of the wheel make
sure you know they don't see me if I'm
on my phone anything like that just to
make sure I'm following all the rules
make sure there's no reason for them to
pull me over the fear of every time you
lose the house is he coming back is very
real for me
I know you're worried about what may
happen to Jackson mm-hmm could you ever
worry about what Jackson they do maybe
he might go out there and just ghost
ride the whip with EcoSmart ghost riding
the risk yes I don't know that's
standard high school stuff
so those ride the whip mr. dance next
two are on top of your car while still
moving ideally with many friends
surrounding a rap music blaring Jackson
you got to tell the people at home what
kind of car you got 2005 for 500 that's
a safe car but what if I told y'all I
can make it safer anything that will
bring him home safe and sound I'm all
about to help Jackson now I headed down
the road star where I hooked up with my
boy is fine he customized his cars like
Quincy Jones customized V he just be
laying that magic damn what's some of
the craziest things you've ever done to
a car making Tigers out er a goat why do
you love customizing cars so much things
the challenge just the fact that you
know if you got a crazy idea and we've
been able to fulfill it and you come to
pick up your car and your jaw's driving
like oh my god so you do it for that do
it for that reaction and the check well
listen man I got a very big project we
already been prepare my ride well this
is what my life
[Music]
I need you and rose star to make this
car safe for a young black man in 2017
so I need y'all to trick it out I shown
it's on my plan and he and his guys got
to work
[Music]
[Applause]
can I show y'all what we did yeah come
on over here so first thing we did and
gave you cameras dawg because the cops
like rules or delete body camera fluids
well damn the cameras we got cameras on
public cameras camera camera camera
camera camera Kayla there's cameras all
over this thing you might also notice
which one a white woman and you passes
aside because statistically right when
we get pulled over the leak in Iraq
because no criminals are doing stuff in
the snow you ever seen that before dawg
he exactly James did it come on now what
are we looking at that says don't to
look sober we just a family on the way
to Legoland produce a non-threatening
stuff we back to that it's pretty much
saying hey cops we on a same team
it's like Kobe pulling over Shaq bad
example it's like LeBron pulled over
Kyrie you filming shining Jackson and
filming let's keep it going
you might notice some diffuser oil so
the cops can't claim that they smell
marijuana smoke not in this car it only
smells like Burke Williams spa
here they're not going to pull you over
they're going to meditate and I put your
Miranda right on the back thing check it
out cause the cops they have this pin to
not read you right but now in the
backseat what is it once exactly you
have the right to remain silent
yep you do and now the crowning
achievement can we see through glove
compartment
we killed it oh my god I'm so clever
now they can see your registration could
we reach that's when they start saying
you might be reaching for something else
now also special bonus feature OOP me
and Roadstar produced a biography of
your life up to this point with all the
highlights all the positive images just
in case the media tries to smear your
image but they deal with my Brown so uh
fool we just woke Joe cool don't you Ron
and anything else but this too dangerous
out here in 2017 no cameras your ski
rack your stickers your diffuser oil
everything mr. Wayne girl and your white
girl listen to mom you covered every
base sad state of affairs that you had
to do that but if it'll bring my son
home I'm all about that one of those
cars were like his car thing should be
later now because of
oh gosh I'm trying
[Music]